good evening and welcome to this
district
planning committee meeting on wednesday
the 9th of june
2021 my name is councillor mark hurd
and i'm chairman of this committee
before we commence
the business of the meeting uh it was
rather
remiss of me and i apologize for this i
didn't introduce
our two new members councillor emma
stevens
from and tollsb bruce hubner
who is representing haybridge and i
welcome you both
to malden district council and i
congratulate you on your election
victory
i would also like to congratulate
councillors wendy stamp
councillor jane fleming and councillor
mark durham on their success
at the recent county council elections
so my congratulations to them
so members housekeeping the setup of the
meeting has been designed to mitigate
for covid
and therefore can i ask all present to
work to the protocols agreed
at the council meeting on the 29th of
april 2021
and in the interest of member and
officer safety
this meeting is streamed live and
recorded and by being present in the
meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers doing each item
please indicate clearly if you wish to
speak and i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members the process this evening will
obviously be different
and therefore i encourage all members to
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please remain
seated
you may remove your mask of course as
you're sitting down
if you wish put on your visor and speak
clearly
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure that you
reference
a page and paragraph number thank you
for your
cooperation we move on now to agenda
item
two apologies for absence
i have received apologies from
councillor dueck
councillor helm councillor jarvis
councillor schemes and councillor miss
white thank you very much thank you
council thompson
uh any other apologies um miss bird
thank you very much we move on to agenda
item three which is minutes of the last
meeting
and it's recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 8th of october
2020
found on pages 7 to 17 are approved
as a true and accurate record
i so move do i have a secondary thank
you councillor maze
if any member wishes to raise any matter
of urgence of accuracy
they need to indicate please their wish
to speak
thank you members can we agree those by
ascent
thank you very much indeed agenda item 4
declarations of
interest this is to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware
should they need a rise throughout the
meeting
do i have any declarations councillor
stan
yes thank you chairman i'd just like to
declare that i am a member of essex
county council and they are statutory
council teams on some of the
applications tonight or all of them
whether they're responded or not
thank you thank you that's noted uh
councillor durham
thank you councillors
thank you very much councillor boyce
um
[Music]
thank you councillor voice counselor
hull
you'll be leaving okay thank you very
much counselor channel beginner thank
you and councillor bell
[Music]
thank you very much indeed okay um
thank you for that members i'll move on
then to the first item which is
agenda item five this is uh two one
stroke zero zero one nine eight slash
v-a-r
land north of marsh road burner on
crouch
and this is found on pages 17 to 26.
members please note that a member's
update in relation to this application
has been circulated prior to the meeting
and this can be found on page
three and four and relates to comments
of
objection um i understand that uh miss
matthews is presenting this report
i'm not sure where you are miss matthews
where are we oh you're there right okay
thank you
so could i ask you then please to
present the report thank you
thank you chairman anyone hear me okay i
think i'm on loudspeaker someone should
be
so this is an application on relating to
land north of marshall road among crouch
and um the application seeks the removal
of one of the conditions
condition 36. okay
i'm sorry captain could i just stop you
there can everybody hear
this no okay
mike
okay is that better is that any better
members
i think the acoustics aren't uh i'm
great here
um as as you're seated miss matthews you
may remove your
uh if you wish
yeah okay and uh
generally a very quiet person but if you
wish to speak up that would be great
is that better well if it's echoey i
can't uh
that's better that's great thank you
thank you members
okay so this is um land north of marsh
road and beneamon crowd and the
application seeks the removal
of condition 36 which was one of the
conditions attached to the original
planning permission
for a residential development of 90
dwellings
and associated works on the application
site
shown on the screen and condition 36
related to a requirement that the
affordable housing
was built to ndss which stands for
national
and nationally determined um space
standard standards
so the site is one of the um allocated
sites in burma crouch
and as allocated for a minimum of 90
dwellings and planned
was granted for 90 dwellings on the site
in december 2020
subject to conditions and following the
completion of a section one agreement
section 106 agreement and 40 of the
houses are to be
affordable homes and the section 106
agreement
requires that the affordable housing is
provided with the minimum room sizes
are defined in the current national
described space standards
and furthermore the details submitted as
part of the current application
discharge of condition application
relating to condition 36
um also comply with the ndss
the requested removal of condition 36
would be in conflict with the
requirements of the completed 106
and the applicant did not object the
imposition of the condition
if the affordable housing units are not
constructed to meet this
um national standards as currently
required it could not be ensured that
all of the affordable units would meet
the greatest current housing needs of
the district
the recommendation may appear to be in
conflict with the conclusions of an
inspector
who determined an appeal in december
2020
relating to land between chandler's and
creaksy lane in burnham
but the points which are made out in the
report is that government
guide advice is that housing may make
use of
um these standards where the need for an
internal space standard can be justified
the standards are it's is explicitly
referred to as part of the
um approved affordable housing and
viability spd adopted by the council
and as part of the appeal and the
inspector acknowledges that spds are
capable of being a material
consideration
and unlike as part of the part of that
appeal um it has
now been demonstrated how this could
make the dwellings unsuitable
and therefore not be able to meet the
identified need
the applicant agrees with the condition
being imposed and willingly entered into
a section 106
containing the same requirement
and so in the absence of a requirement
to comply with these standards local
authority could not ensure that the
affordable housing proposed met the
greatest housing needs of the district
i don't know whether they're not
particularly relevant to the application
but i did take some photos of the site
the other day to show
work has commenced on site but in
conclusion
and officers consider the condition is
necessary
relevant for the planning relevant to
the development to be permitted
enforceable precise and reasonable in
all other respects
and on this basis is recommended that
the application is refused thank you
thank you uh miss matthews now um we
have one public participant for this
planning application and lined with the
public participation scheme
i will now invite the applicant mr
uh cassion on behalf of taylor wimpey i
hope i said your name correct
thank you to read out his
submission and i have to remind you that
you are allocated two minutes only
for public speaking in accordance with
the scheme so
mr mr cassian thank you
thank you chair and good evening
everyone my name is sam caslin and i'm
the planning manager at taylor wimpy
london
i'm grateful for the opportunity to be
with you here with you this evening and
speak in support of this application
in august 2020 this committee resulted
grant permission for 90 homes on the
site
including 40 affordable homes it was
well after the committee and at the 11th
hour of the legal agreement being signed
the officers at the council added on
condition 36
i.e after the new homes were already
considered acceptable by this council
at the time this was happening taylor
wimpey could not accommodate more delay
to progressing the site so reluctantly
we agreed to add this condition
it is worth noting that this was before
the appeal decision at creek c
and had we seen that appeal we would
have likely taken a very different
position
the development plan against which all
planning applications in this borough
should be determined does not require
any compliance with the ndss
the planning inspector for the recent
david wilson's home appeal and the lab
between chadler's and crete sea lane
site considered this very matter
and concluded that current planning
policy cannot require such compliance
whilst officers at the council have put
forward further information following
our application
we believe that this still comes under
the banner of what the inspector
considered in coming to his decision
with regard to the legal agreement
attached to the permission this already
includes an ndss related requirement
unless agreed otherwise which he did at
the original planning committee
national planning practice guidance is
clear that there should not be any
duplication between planning
contributions and obligation
planning conditions and obligations
within legal agreements which is what we
have in this instance
given all of this we strongly believe
that the addition of condition 36 is
unjustified and hence
why we have applied to remove it i will
close this by adding the
assurance that these homes are not small
and would not be poor quality
just like the market homes that are
popular with our customers they comply
with the ndess
in terms of internal floor space so
they're not small they're just not in
full compliance with formal storage and
bedroom sizes
these are high quality buildings and
will be fantastic homes for future
residents
thank you thank you very much indeed
before i open this debate any other
officers wish to speak on this
no thank you very much members i now
open the debate
and invite you to put any questions or
make any comments
that you have on your report council of
voice
well the recommendation is
the recommendation is to refuse that has
been proposed
and seconded members are you
happy to agree that by ascent
right anybody else uh council swain
i'll just hear what councillor swain has
to say first thank you
yes i would like to ask one of your
questions
um the first question is
would derogation from these national
standards
compromise the numbers and types of
accommodation
were shown in the table 3.1.7 i think it
is
but secondly there seems to be some
dispute about the relationship with the
um an spd to the ldp
um about uh introducing whether it's
introducing a new planning positive but
having said that we have got written in
the
section 206 agreement and i suppose we
can rely on that
even though there may be some argument
of the relevant
relevance of their prixy decision
um lastly i would like to say that
um from a reputational point of view i
don't think it
does become much good to be seen to be
trying to
go below national minimum standards
thank you tony
thank you is uh sorry was there a
question in there first of all or
was that a comment
was that a comment or a question council
so i didn't quite catch it well
the first two were questions okay the
effect on the numbers and types of
accommodation
are we looking for if we reduce these
allow a reduction in sanders and
i suppose it was a comment that we can
meteorical question rely upon the
section 106 agreement anyway
okay thank you mr mr leo
do you need to come back on there miss
matthews the effect on the number of
um dwellings
the type of dwellings yeah through
german um
my housing colleague may may want to
chip in and
i'll um explain my understanding of it
um but in terms of the table at 3.1.7
that what that wouldn't change and the
proposal isn't to reduce the number of
affordable units or the percentage of
affordable units or even
change the housing mix that proposed and
my understanding of the issue is in
particular
with two pers no two beds
four person units and we've the council
has had experience of
developers who have built two-person
um two-bedroom four-person units but the
um
the the bedrooms aren't quite big enough
for the four four people
and so they've so they've they've had to
be let as
um two pers two bedroom three person
units and not two per
two bedroom four person units um and
that's because they didn't meet the nd
ss standard for two bedroom four person
units
um so uh so there's no
change as such to the the affordable
housing proposed it's just the
um that particular issue has has cropped
up in the past and
this is why we've started to try and
firm these things up before the
permission needs granted to make sure
that
the the problems that we've experienced
in the past don't reoccur
and we do have the um the section 106
but
i would suggest that if if the council
agrees to the condition being removed
that is um it would be quite difficult
i would have thought to um
enforce the section 106 requirements
because the council has been seen to
be agreeing the ndss standards aren't
aren't necessary
and there will be a would be a process
to go through um
to get that change on the 106 but um
that at the moment they are compatible
if the condition is removed then they
would become
incompatible and there will be an issue
there that we need to be
sorted out legally um
i think there's a question about the
relationship between the spd and the ldp
so the ldp is the overarching
development plan
with the overarching policies and the
spds we've got a number of spd's that
have sought
to expand on the policy and um
support the policies that are in the
local plan so we've got so we've got for
example the design
guide is an spd which supports policy at
d1 which talks about design
so it goes into a lot more detail and so
whilst the spd isn't a policy in its own
right
it is linked to the local plan um
because it's it's um come out of the
policies in the local plan and been
developed
um in the framework of the the local
plan that we've
approved and i think that answers
your questions um thank you okay thank
you ms matthews councillor thompson
whether damien is able to um expand a
little bit with a bit more authority
than me
thank you
are reduced um that we're less able to
help those people
have a two bedroom four person league
there are more households where you have
two children in the house
so therefore
uh as well i'd just like to know
if the space stand is ignored there's a
possibility that commercials attractive
and therefore
um
okay thank you very much thank you um
councillor lagoon
through chairman um yes they they
did agree to it it was it was added on
but it was done with their knowledge and
and agreement was my understanding i
wasn't involved with the application
that time but that is
what i understand the case but they do
but the developer had already signed up
or agreed to
section 106 agreement which had a very
similar requirement so
um there wasn't any reason really for
them to
um disagree
thank you any other members wish to
speak counselor stan um yes thank you
chairman um i'd like to
praise the officers for the
recommendation um
we shouldn't be giving in they stand
minimum standards there for a reason and
they protect our
affordable housing needs and the
residents who need them i think the
um the planning appeal in question
failed on a different matter and i would
certainly back uh councillor boyce and
agree
with the recommendation to refuse this
application thank you chairman
any other members wish to speak
yes i'll just hear what council hull has
to say
all right that's noted thank you um
so we have had a request for a recorded
vote is that seconded
councillor lagan thank you very much um
tara could you do the roll call please
so this is for the occur for the
officer's recommendation to refuse
[Music]
four members you
specialist
or
[Music]
i will abstain
[Music]
[Music]
or
[Music]
okay did you did you get a chance to
vote councillor swain
i missed it did you get a chance to vote
you did okay
all right thank you so i declare uh that
that application then is
refused in line with the officer's
recommendation
we move on then to agenda item number
six
uh this is uh
two one treble zero seven five
o utm land 250 meters north
of 16 a malden road
burnham
thank you councillor hull good night
so members we move to this agenda item
it's found on pages
27 to 76. please note that a member's
update in relation to this application
has been circulated prior to the meeting
and this is found on pages
5 to 10 and contains changes of
conditions and consultations
again i think miss matthews if you're
able to present this report please
thank you chairman yes so um in addition
to the
updates on the written written members
update that has been previously
circulated
and the uh there's a
couple of further updates and one is in
relation to condition
six and which talks about the dwelling
mix
that has slightly changed since the
report was first drafted
um in terms of the bungalows so we've
now
got um 42 one bed bungalows
62 bed bungalows and 33 bed bungalows
and two further updates um a petition a
petition has been received with 205
signatures and it's been submitted by
the agent for the application
in support of the application on the
basis that the facility is much needed
to serve the local
and broad community and we've also
received an
nhs response today and they have
required or requested
a sum of 87 400 pounds
as a financial contribution and to
mitigate the impact of the development
on local gp provision
and which the applicant has agreed to
so this is a run application with all
matters of detail reserved
except for layout and means of access to
the site
the application is for 132 one two three
bedroom bungalows a hundred one two and
three bedroom apartments
in two story buildings and the erection
of a single-story ancillary multi-use
community building
the bungalows will be in groups of
between eight and twenty and all the
residential units
would be for the over 55s
this is to be phase two of a development
and
phase one which is being called burnham
waters by the developer
and was previously approved and
is adjacent to the south and western
boundaries of the application site
and phase one included healthcare and
leisure facilities
this application is shown on your screen
there it says an l-shaped
area of land which extends to about 20
hectares
and it's located within the countryside
around 50 meters from burnham moncract's
settlement boundary at its closest point
to the south and east of the site are a
collection of existing properties
fronting maldon road
green lane and mangaps chase to the
north and east are arable fields
and there are public right-of-ways
crossing and within the vicinity of the
site
this is an aerial photo showing the site
edged in red
you've got the blue box there which is
phase one
and we've got the pink dots there which
is the malden road
and you've also got the blue line there
which is the panels
brook watercourse
so this is the layout that has been
submitted
um
so and there'll be 74 one bedroom
units 106 two bed units and 52 three bed
units in total
thirty percent of the harvard earth
housing provision would be met
with a combination of on-site units
including a group of bungalows
to the southeastern corner of the site
which are these um
brown um rectangles um here in the
corner
and also a financial contribution and
for the balance of
the affordable housing requirement
and there'll be a margin of native tree
and shrub planting
proposed along the outer edge of the
site which will contain
a three meter wide and perimeter
footpath which would link with
that path approved as part of phase one
there's
the permissive bridal way agreed as part
of phase one will also be extended to
the east through
this phase two so on this layout here
you've got the orange
and blocks down to the south which will
be standard
standard flats and then to the north of
there you have
a group of waterfront flats
and and then the the others would be
um single-story bungalows so and said in
groups of eight to 20
and around and they've called them own
their own little um
communities
a management company will be established
for the grounds maintenance foul and
surface water drainage and other utility
services and
um that would be required through a
related section 106 agreement
as part of the previous approval public
transport contribution of 75 000 was
secured
and there will be a best service would
serve at the site and a minimum service
to be provided by the
developer along with electric cycles and
electric buggies will also be available
for residents
particularly taking into account the
planning history of their joining site
it's considered the site has a
reasonable level of accessibility
the occupiers of site would not be
overly reliant on the use of private
vehicles
which weighs in favour of the proposal
the details of the affordable scheme
including tenure costs allocation of
units would be agreed
with in consultation with the housing
manager as part of compliance with the
section 106 agreement which is suggested
they've got some photos here they said
this is along malden road looking east
and west
street scene and walden road that's to
the east of the
uh site again this is what it
um basically lies at the moment so these
these are
where the phase one development would go
and then the
photos of the uh the expanded site
um so i haven't got copies of all these
photos or these viewpoints
but there's a selection so we've got um
um they'll be in order so you've got one
there and
four and six and seven
and eleven
so that's a few point one and four and
six so six
is from the public footpath which
is runs a long part of the site and cuts
across through it
and viewpoint 7 and 11 so it's
just see the arable fields there so in
conclusion the development has been
assessed as being acceptable in
principle overall
taking into account the substantial
benefits the proposal which would
outweigh the harm the development of
cause to the character appearance of the
area and their limits on accessibility
in particular the provision of
specialist housing for the elderly
which modern district residents would be
given priority to would weigh heavily in
favor of the development particularly
currently
when there is only 3.26 years of housing
land supply
as soon as the reserve matters are
approved or
if they are approved and development
would start contributing to the
council's five-year
housing land supply and and bearing in
mind that phase one
gained approval for reserve matters well
within two years of the outlying
permission having been granted
and that shouldn't be too too long too
far away
and there will also be economic benefits
noted in the report
the development is not anticipated to
cause harm to the immunity of the
occupiers of neighbouring
existing residents highway safety or
nature conservation
and it's also been found to be
satisfactory in terms of flood risk and
drainage
issues in contamination ecology could be
addressed by conditions
and adequate levels of parking could be
made
the applicant has agreed to enter one to
106 to address matters arising relation
to offsite medical provision
road junction capacity issues off-site
nature conservation impacts and
affordable housing
including financial contribution in the
region of 4.2 million pounds
the proposed heads of agreement include
a requirement that no development on
phase 2 shall commence
until the 90th dwelling of phase 1 has
been completed
and is ready for occupation and until
the healthcare community
centre shops and minibus service
approved part phase one has been
constructed
and are operational on this basis it's
recommended that planning permission is
granted
subject to 106 and conditions are set
out in the report
thank you chairman thank you miss
matthews
so we have one public participant for
this planning application and in line
with the public participation
scheme i will now invite the agent mr
rowe to read out his submission
now i remind you mr rowe that you are
allocated two minutes only
for public speaking in accordance with
the scheme thank you
good evening chairman and members i'm
stuart rowe a chartered town planner and
the agent for the applicant
the first phase of the retirement
community was approved in 2019 because
the council recognised that it could not
provide for the significant needs
of its elderly population on allocated
sites which are controlled by
large house builders who don't build
retirement homes
precisely the same planning policy
circumstances that applied in 2019
remain in effect now
and those same policies support the
grant of permission for this second
phase
which will further assist in meeting the
continuing acute need for retirement
homes in the district there is a new
matter which members will be familiar
with and possibly dread the lack of a
five-year housing supply
however this application doesn't rely
upon that for primary support
like phase one the second phase is
acceptable on its merits when tested
against the development plan
and it would be inconsistent i think to
find otherwise
the lack of a five-year supply adds
weight to the argument but not
uh it's not the reason that you should
grant permission the reason is because
the district has a significant need for
elderly persons accommodation that
otherwise won't be met
the lack of a housing supply will
encourage a raft of applications for
ordinary housing
which will not meet these needs yet will
be hard for you to resist
the shortfall in housing of around 500
homes will come
they will be approved if not by the
council then by
inspectors at appeal they will not be
necessarily where you want them to be or
the type that best fits
the needs in the district but they will
come if approved this development will
deliver about 40 percent of that need
and make it less acute in one go this
would assist you in defending
appeals against other unacceptable
proposals
this will provide high quality
retirement homes and a 4.2 million
contribution so that the council can
provide affordable housing
elsewhere in the district i hope that
you can see from the report that the
benefits of the scheme
far outweigh any adverse consequences
and can grant planning permission this
evening
thank you thank you very much indeed mr
ro
now now members
um i know that uh members of the public
listening to this are having trouble um
hearing what your comments are
um i think that burner has got a roving
microphone so to try and improve the
sound quality
um she will be coming along to try and
uh
see if we can help things along so we'll
give that uh we'll give that a go
so members i'm now going to open the
debate and
invite you to put any questions or
comments
that you have um to the report
councillor stan
thank you chairman before i actually do
speaks i'm going to give way to the rest
of the members there's something i think
needs to be said from the ch
from me i would like to say chairman
that before
we do actually start the debate it is
important in my view
that members are aware that i was made
aware that somebody or bodies have been
knocking on doors around the parts of
burnham on crouch
and allegedly saying that they are
representing the council
i wish to make it quite clear to all
members and members of the public
that modern district council and their
representatives have not
been knocking on any doors saying that
they're collecting information or data
i think that is really important
chairman that we make that clear
thank you thank you leader
um so councillor durham and then
councillor morris
thank you thank you chairman uh the
officer um mentioned the
impact on the five-year land supply i
wonder if she could put a figure to that
uh to tell us approximately how far
this would go to solving the five-year
land supply
issue should this be granted please
miss matthews
um i think i'll um i think mr lee knows
the figures off the top of his head more
than i do
um
um
during the presentation um this
applicant has moved forward with the
reserve matters quite quickly and we
would
be able to make an assumption for the
calculation that that would likely to
happen
again with phase two and
that would be evidenced if they are able
to meet their required or their
apparent deadlines for commencing
development um this summer
because one of the ways that you work
out the five-year land supply is
actually to show that they're
deliverable so you have to provide
evidence and generally there's a
formula that you use to work out but if
you can evidence that there will be some
developments will be quicker
some events will be slower um the amount
of number that goes into the
development in the five-year land supply
falls away and with this in mind
you know to be honest i haven't actually
thought about this in any
detail so it would be very very off the
cuff
um rather than excluding the first two
years
of should normally do with the reserve
matters before the application i'd say
that you'd probably have to knock
two years off so i would say that very
roughly on the sort of general
estimation i'd say this would add 120
dwellings to our
five-year land supply instantly which is
which is not a demonstrable figure it's
a notable figure on a short four of this
level but
that is very much and we're going to
prepare at the moment just literally
thinking fingernails i
hadn't prepped for that but just taking
into account my knowledge of working out
the private land supply
i'd estimate that where if for example
it was an application that a land trader
for example to put the application
rather than personally bringing forward
themselves
that would elongate the process and
would reduce the number of dwellings
that would instantly go into the
five-year land supply
and then if you're somewhere in the
middle with a normal corporate builder
that hasn't
evidenced a speedy delivery in malden
you would be somewhere in the middle so
that gives you just a rough guide on the
calculation but as i said it's very much
a
bringing a prayer so take that into
account with the appropriate weight
but please don't quote me thank you
thank you thank you very much
so we'll just take the microphone over
to councillor morris
if we may need it well i'm thinking of
members of the public counselor maurice
so
if you want to go around the back thank
you very much
so do please uh bear with us um
members and uh we'll try and uh make it
as clear as we can for all
okay thanks um thank you chair
i would like to propose that we do not
take the officer's recommendation
and that we refuse this i'll ask for a
second to please
balkan scale okay
well we'll we'll continue with the
debate for the moment
um councillor lagan i think did you have
your hand up yes
that's right um
yeah i agree with uh councillor morris
um i received a letter today from the
developer
which was quite intimidating in its tone
um basically saying you know look we
have to
we have to do this because otherwise
it's going to be forced upon us
um i don't think this council should be
scared of making a decision
uh that's best for the residents and i
agree with councillor morris that the
the size of this second extension or
this extension to the initial proposal
would be demonstrable in its size
and at the moment is not currently
needed so i'm not prepared to support
this
thank you i'll i'll move now to
counselor channel
thank you thank you chairman apologize
but i've got bad hay fever
um chairman just a couple of questions
here for me
um bearing in mind what we're hearing
from mr leon officers and i'm well aware
of the fact about our housing
land supply in the five years and the
figure etcetera might be required
we are actually at the moment conducting
a review of our local plan as recovered
by the government and we're doing that
and starting it early
due to the fact we are aware of our
five-year housing land supply
therefore could it be considered this
application might be considered
premature bearing in mind we have done a
call for sites
and we're going through a process with
our planning policy working group
ultimately we'll go to strategy and
resources and then on to council
so therefore there may be other sites
which may actually be more
suitable to actually develop to help us
with our housing numbers
so that's one first question because i
do recall something along those lines i
think being said
throughout the process of the previous
ldp considerations
also i noticed the list of statutory
consultees
i was rather interested to see there had
been nothing that has come forward from
essex housing
i recall at the last application on
phase one essex housing actually did not
support
phase one although i had to say i didn't
recall it being called phase one at that
time
and this phase two is a whole new sort
of gamut to me i wasn't familiar that
any other application would be coming in
although i have to say i
did sort of privately consider i could
perhaps see something like this coming
forward
at a further stage but i noticed there's
no response from essex housing did we go
to essex housing
and they were quite clear they could not
support the previous application
so i just asked those questions to start
with chairman and would i ask if it's
not too presumptuous if i
need to in light of the debate may i
come back with further questions as they
arise because
often the debate can get you thinking
you'll never use perhaps you hadn't
considered before you entered the
meeting
thank you thank you i have got a couple
of other um
hands up but i'll go to um
are you able to answer that that
question matt please
do chairman um if i can ask
catherine matthews to pick up the
console t1 and um
see she's the case officer i'm happy to
pick up the other ones and
as quite possibly i'll miss something if
matthews can pick that up
afterwards i'll be more than happy that
um in relation to
or before i get on to council channel's
points can i just make one comment into
statement made by councillor lagan about
currently not needed
all i'd like to evidence is that we are
unable to demonstrate a five-year land
supply so the council is unable to say
that
there isn't need for housing per se and
the strategic housing market assessment
that we had
before the ldp said we needed over 600
house and i can't be the exact figure
to through the local planned period to
meet the need for old people housing
specifically
and at the moment we have phase one and
i think it's around 30 dwellings through
the street at site so
i would be very concerned about a
statement saying it's not currently
needed because
the evidence would say that there is a
current need whether or not you agree
with this is the right side is a
different question
but there is evidence that there is a
current need so i think members just
need to be
very aware of that now that we're
dealing with the lack of five lands
financially balance where
the development starts in favor you know
presumption is in favor of the
development
um the fact that you have to
be able to show demonstrable harm that
you know where harm out comes the
benefit so i just think
members need to be very aware of maybe
using correct terminology and things i
just want to give some guidance to say
that
saying there's currently not needed
would be false because there is evidence
to say that but um just for clarity
um in relation to the threatening email
i'm not going to comment on that point
you know the applicant has a right to
communicate with members and um it's
within their gift to do that as they
wish but
you know that's not from part of the
officer's recommendation
does not perform a part of the report
and to some extent
as i always advise all members around
correspondence received
outside of the plan application
processes to give it the appropriate
weight because it's not been evidenced
or commented on
by officers so as always i'd advise
members to
give that limited weight irrespective of
what it contained um
in relation to the new local plan and uh
could this be
classed as premature the answer is no
the new local plan will take a period to
be delivered and in that time we are
required to deliver
housing we are we will be required to
meet the housing needs of the district
um
an argument that this is premature would
not be the right argument whether or not
you think it's an appropriate site for
housing
whether harm the benefits outweigh
whether harm significantly etc is a
separate conversation but
any argument around prematurity would be
premature because we aren't at that
point
where we can actually strongly say that
the ldp is here and what's coming
forward
we haven't even got a strategy on
housing growth or anything like that so
we are nowhere near far enough down the
road on reviewing the ldp
to be saying that we're in a strong
position to be able to
demonstrate housing and not withstanding
that we still need to provide the
housing for the current period
the new ldp will provide housing for the
future period so there is still that
window of time at the moment where we
wouldn't need to be delivering
housing um
just and to comment on council channel's
point about another application yet
it was not formally part of the
application that this was a phase one
you know the applicant has
deemed it phase one to submit a second
application the fact that that was never
advised that was part of the first
application shouldn't be material
consideration of this application
it should be determined on whether or
not it's acceptable or not and if i pass
over to ms matthews to
for the consulting point and anything
else i missed thank you chairman
thank you very much um i'm going
councillor chan are you happy with the
answer
right okay thank you very much i'm going
to move next to councillor siddal
next
uh yeah i do recognize that there is a
need for this type of housing
in in the district and we do need to
build this this type of housing
uh however i really don't think this is
the right location
and the right design for this type of
housing
uh i'd be interested to hear what the
consultant
said on this particular why we didn't
hear from the essex county council
because we did last time and last time
it was a smaller site
and essex county council said it was not
a suitable location
for a retirement village so why are we
building war
at this at this particular location um
i have a question for miss masters about
the public rights away
how would someone access it what would
it be like to walk through
and because people don't have private
gardens on this development
would you end up walking through
someone's property
because you might get a bit confused and
lost by the density of what's going on
in terms of the density if this was
being put
say in one of our other locations that
is a development site
would it be acceptable would we be
allowing this type of density
in other other locations uh it's
it's so it's not the best fit for our
needs so i do see the need
but it's not the best fit for our need
the
interesting thing about the agent in his
presentation is he admitted
that there are adverse consequences so
the agent sees
and has said in his two minutes that
there was adverse consequences
to this particular development and i
don't see
those being outweighed by what we've
been presented with
thank you thank you so mr lee
do we know about the the list of
consultees no
no response from essex housing ms
matthews
through chairman essex county council
social services was um
consulted on the applications um i think
i think that's um the objection or the
concerns that um
have been referred to in terms of phase
one and they were consulted but we
didn't get a response from them
and so that's about that's all like
all the information i i have on that
okay and the public rights of way
chairman so on that point
expansion of slight expansion in
relation to the evidence capital council
queries
so essex county council did not support
the first phase it was considered
outside the boundary but placed two
um they're not involved because they're
not proposing the extra care properties
essex council council are only involved
in extra care
affordable property so that's where
their interest sits
we would nominate from our own register
for people in the district
all right thank you very much um i'm
going to move to councillor swain now
who's indicated any other members wish
to speak on this
yeah okay yes i've got your name
councilman thank you councillor swain
first thank you
thank you chairman um
yes it's it's noticeable how easily
we've slipped into this
discussion of phase one and phase two um
and
my first reaction was um
was this all part of a big scheme anyway
because if it had
had this been put forward originally in
its totality
i can't believe it it would have been
passed at all
despite the some minor
references to preferences for people in
the district
um and the rather strange comment that
two kilometers isn't really very far to
walk particularly
bearing in mind the sort of people who
these um this accommodation is designed
for
um but i think it goes to the heart of
the problem
that this was always a hybrid
development
the idea of retirement village and
provision of
supported housing should we say um
on the same site is it just doesn't
follow the retirement village
is usually a distinct separate
self-contained community
apart from an existing settlement
whereas the assisted housing and so only
very much has to be integrated in
a settlement and i think uh
compounding this by adding on this
so-called phase two
simply really just produces a suburb
of um of burnham and doesn't meet either
of the
uh objectives of either of a retirement
village
or um uh adequate facilities for
um uh for supported housing
i note the reference there to the nhs
has said previously in the first round
that they were not in favor of more
elderly
accommodation in burling because of the
inaccessibility of hospital services um
i'm rather bothered about the finance in
all of this
there are so many commitments
commitments long-term commitments to
providing all sorts of social
and community facilities
and supposedly all going to be
self-financing
um i really would like to have an
independent
examination of this financial viability
particularly as the
applicant has said that this would be in
perpetuity
and which so to come back to the
the basics of the decision i think it
fails on the first one about the
principle of this development
um because of the contradiction
internal contradiction of the retirement
village and the assisted housing
um okay could i could you just sum up
yes i would not support this but i would
um
ask whether a possibility that perhaps
it could be deferred pending an
independent assessment of the viability
of the whole scheme
of phase one and phase two because it
seems to me quite likely
that phase two may be necessary for the
viability of the social
and commercial facilities of phase one
okay um councillor bassinger
you're next
thank you mr chairman um i was just
wondering through you if i could ask
mr lee um he says that you know it's
heavily
the weight of this heavily relies on the
fact that we need
houses for the elderly i just wondered
how we collated that evidence what what
is the evidence for that is there is
there a sort of do we have a
plethora of elderly people in burnham
without houses or is are we just looking
at
generally across the country so on what
basis
is this evidence gained
miss matthew say you're able to do that
german i can answer that one
no mr gale might want to
assist on that but um the council has
the strategic housing market assessment
which is
a document that evidence bases the
requirements for the
housing for the district morgan is one
of the most aging districts in the
country
and as i explained the shma required
over 600 houses through the local plan
period for
older people it's
it was an adopted document the evidence
was challenged and
critiqued through the local plan process
and
found to be accurate and to be
correct so
yeah can't say much more than that
really so it's hands yeah
that is for housing not affordable
housing not evidence for homelessness
this is just what
the district needs and this application
is a market scheme
it's offering affordable housing whether
it's on site off site through
financial contribution of policy
compliance so
it is a market driven scheme just like
any other application
it is aiming at providing or meeting
that need
um that is required and our
spd in relation to affordable housing
requires that
allocated requires that affordable
housing or not sorry any housing aimed
at older people
is located in haybridge malden or
burnham rather than being located
across the district because of access to
facilities for day-to-day living et
cetera
so basically our policy says we need a
certain number of properties that has
been evidence-based and our policy says
they should be inhabited
or burnham and that's why you know the
officer paul explains that thank you
chairman
thank you all right i've got uh
councillor thompson
then morris then boyle and then
councillor bell
so i'll go uh and council amaze okay so
counselor
yes i i did put in the chat the order
of the uh speakers uh and uh councillor
voice
should be next please i see okay
i'm looking at you through through to
screen
i can i can see you now well i've been
i've been waving my hand for
from the start of the debate and you
have consistently
ignored me so i assumed you couldn't see
me
um chairman um
i believe um as i stated
in my declaration of interest that the
first time that phase one
came before the council i voted against
it as i
think mrs channel did and i think we're
probably the only two here
that actually voted against the scheme
in the first place
but as i went on to say that
once it became the council's decision i
i then approached it in an entirely
different manner
as somebody has said that
um we didn't know that phase two was
coming when phase one
was um agreed and
i believe also like that uh maybe
councillor swain
i believe that that would have made a
difference to the original
debate what are we looking for if
we go ahead with this a phase three a
phase four
of phase five i know you can only
determine what you have in front of you
and not what may be
into the future however
i i would support councillor morris's
proposal if there is sufficient
grounds planning grounds
to oppose it and i would reserve the
right chairman
if his motion goes down
to come back on the new substantive
motion
with some other issues thank you
chairman
thank you thank you councillor boyce
councillor morris
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
ask um
is our three-bedroom retirement
thank you very much
did you want to come back on that mr lee
chairman um
this authority his committees have
accepted three-bedroom
annexes holder people said um but what i
would say is
and as you know many members wouldn't
know um
there's the potential for whatever
reasons in the future that a couple may
not wish to share a bed
medical grounds etc um you know one of
them may be on oxygen so they would have
to have it on through the night and
they're going to sleep in another room
and
this is a retirement property it doesn't
mean they wouldn't want to have guests
they're allowed to have somebody come to
stay they're allowed to have a
study if they wish this isn't affordable
in relation to any restrictions in
relation to
their benefits or any restrictions about
that this is a as i said a market led at
property and
for that reason i don't see any reasons
we could object to the idea
that a retirement property may wish to
include three bedrooms
thank you chairman okay thank you very
much councillor thompson is next
sorry um i've got to say i've not from
everything i've seen
like most members i'm not wild about
this application
on this proposal um anywhere there's an
application though you can always wait
for the next one and the next one and
the next one even if the land's not in
the same ownership we know how these
things
progress along the road um but i have
the same problem as council of boyce in
that i can't support a refusal on the
basis of balkan size and and no need
because we can see there's no need
that we could see there's a need because
we're sitting here
making decisions for the whole district
not for any
part of the district and not for our
awards
and i for me i'm afraid bulk and size
without a lot more to it doesn't cover
something that i think i could support
thank you chairman thank you very much
um sorry the other side of the room now
councillor bella
thank you and thank you mr chairman um
members i'm just not entirely sure what
we're looking at here because the
agent has told us it's a retirement
community it's more housing for the
elderly
however the refusal of another
large elderly provision recently
evidence is that berlin doesn't
in fact need any more elderly housing
and actually we've taken far more in
relation to the
shma than actually we should have
and in fact the applicant themselves
admits that uh the independent slash
assisted living element will probably
not be appropriate or required
solely in addition in additional units
in phase two
might be considered an over provision in
the area
so members do we have an elderly
retirement community or do we just have
a very large housing estate
because if we just have a very large
housing estate
it is neither a strategic site nor is a
garden suburb
and therefore it falls outside all of
the burnham
and malden district council policies as
far as i can see
thank you thank you councillorvell
i'm going to go back to the leader in a
moment just to uh
just to sum up are there any other
members that wish to speak
i'd like to speak yes i was coming to
you yes okay in that case leader
uh thank you chairman um if you're just
bear with me because i've taken a few
notes when i was reading this afternoon
so i've got a few questions
the heads of terms section 106 agreement
i've got two different ones so
one says that the medical center and all
the facilities will be built
before phase two can have confirmation
that is true and i asked that members
because my main area of concern is the
medical center
i have tried to get contact with the nhs
today to find out if this medical center
is going to be equipped
and for members who maybe don't realize
that when the previous application
for phase one came out we were promised
at all sorts of burnham town council
like an mri scanner i've tried to get
information
that will justify and give members full
information because i think you need to
be fully informed
on how you're going to vote it's all
right having a medical center etc but
unless the nhs
is going to provide for it is a personal
is it a private
practice um so forgive me i couldn't get
the information to bring i don't know if
the officers have more information
because i think this is critical
this is an assistant assisted living old
people's
retirement village and we have to make
sure we look after our residents don't
stick them in the middle of a field
outside on the edge of
a settlement that it is outside the
development boundary
um it is actually three minutes at three
kilometers
to the um town centre and i'm looking at
5.3.1.33
i just want to correct some of the
information in the office's report so
please forgive me i'm not being
difficult or picky um but
three kilometers i think um cancer swain
said i think he said two kilometers it's
actually three kilometres according to
some of the other information
we don't have banks we don't have
building societies
we do luckily have cafes and coffee
shops etc
we also have a long walk into town where
these facilities are going to be used
now i myself i know you're going to be
surprised members do qualify to go into
this retirement village
i know you're all shocked i don't look
as though i'm over 55 but sadly i am
i do think i would personally like some
clarity on
what the um applicants i think it's in
his own report
i think it's their planning and design
bureau limited
planning statement and if you look at
page 55 if members have got it
6.18 and and i think this has been
mentioned before so chairman if you'll
allow me just to have a little bit
longer than maybe i should have
the development would generally satisfy
assimilate
into the existing countryside subject
the planning and landscaping proposed
however from three viewpoints to the
east and the northwest
phase two development would result in a
minor adverse impact on the landscape
and cannot be mitigated now i think
we've all debated
whether it's minor or major in the past
because it depends what your viewpoint
is i personally don't think it's minor i
think it's major
i think it's further development on a on
a field
and to me it's sprawling yeah it's okay
we've got phase one
that could maybe be accommodated and
mitigated by the number of trees and the
way it was
agreed with the hard work at this
committee of this council to agree
landscaping
this is actually going to go all the way
around you so it members and then i'll
shape that went down the back of
people's back gardens that are already
on there
i have i do have a problem with the word
minor i personally don't see it's minor
i think it's major
the harm to the character and the
intrinsic beauty of the countryside must
weigh against the development
and his attributed moderate weight
having regard to the character of impact
and the limited number of viewpoints
concerned now i think that breaches
um and i have brought my ldp this time
um so i can actually
state what policy it breaches if that's
okay members policy s estimate
and policy states quite clearly in our
ldp
the countryside will be protected for
its landscape
natural resources and ecological value
as well as its intrinsic character and
beauty
well i actually think it's a beautiful
field i think bernie i think we've got
beautiful green areas
and i do think as a council it's not
just burnham because i'm the ward member
i'm
modern district council leader we have
to promote we have to protect
our beautiful green spaces now if there
is a need
and i think mr lee said that quite
clearly there was a lead a need
but the affordable housing content of
here this development site is not going
to be here it's going to be a commuted
sum
that goes somewhere else um i i'm i am i
know i'm getting a bit
above myself members but i've got one
more before you stop me chairman
6.19 based on the assessments undertaken
today
the only other matter that could be said
to weigh against the proposal
is that the site lies some distance from
the town centre
now that is on their own the developers
own health impact assessment
this could be said to attract
considerable weight against
the proposal particularly having regard
to the scale
of the development however this
statement explains that the site is
accessible to burnham crouch town centre
by bust and cycle now i live on the
malden road and i'm always amazed when
it says we have a regular bus service
i see the school bus going down in the
morning and i see the school bus going
back i don't see a regular one
except for christmas i think they do a
christmas one i know the developer
because i've read the the pack because i
can see them looking at me within the
wrong glasses
they are looking at having dart so
they're actually
got some suns to be able to produce a
bus service what we've got to remember
is we've got small estate roads within
this site
yeah so you're not going to you're not
going to have big buses so if it goes
into phase
2 phase 3 they're going to be small
sites small road sites
now i'm really concerned that
it says quite clearly in all their
literature
that you know we don't need to worry
about education
contributions because people who live
here you know go into these uh this
retirement village it is not necessary
but it states quite clearly
that other homes three-bedroom the
four-bedroom homes will be given up for
people to downsize and go into
retirement village
to me one more minute please it's really
important i don't speak very often
uh so sorry i maybe do sorry members
and but because mr lee will know what
i'm going to say here
it does it will affect our education
now if we are freeing up houses and
around burnham on crotch because this is
where this development is going to be
it's going to it's going to hopefully
serve the whole of the district but it
will
free up houses in burnham so it's going
to create and add to our infrastructure
shortage
and i'm sorry chairman i know you're
going to shut me up but i've got so many
other things but i think it
it fails it fails on i
i do think i must start i'm grateful for
that thank you very much indeed
um before i go to the vote council
marcie you wanted to make it
some questions answered please i did
actually ask some questions yes
mr lee yeah thank you chairman there's
been quite a few questions asked over
the last
few members quit so um i'll be honest
i've bullet pointed things so i might
end up saying answering something that
wasn't a question i may miss the exact
question because of the time and i
apologize
one thing i would just want to comment
on is
point raised by councillor thompson into
relation to balkan
size but also to echo the point
on design that was also said by a member
earlier
this is outline in nature we don't
necessarily have those pieces of
information before us particularly
design
and this is potentially bulk so if
members do have concerns with the
proposal in relation to the
development just need to be very
conscious this is outlining
nature only with land uh i think it's
access and layout so we don't have the
design and the scale of the development
in front of us per se so just be very
conscious of
wording if you do have issues with the
application
one of the issues i've also would like
to kind of stop
it's about the fact that it was just
always part of a bigger scheme and will
there be a
phase three four and five etcetera
whatever your beliefs on
this are it can't be a material
consideration determination of this
application
each application is assessed on its own
merits we are where we are with this
application
i can't comment on whether or not
officers would have supported a scheme
of this scale
originally um but we have granted phase
one and we are in a situation where
phase two has been submitted at time
where we haven't got five year land
supply
um if members go on commission or it's
allowed to appeal when a phase three
comes in
would assess the application with what
submitted
and the situation we are at the time so
your beliefs
in your heart on that matter just please
don't give any weight as a material
consideration and termination
application
um i'm assuming councilor bell was
referring to
petty crow's application and i just want
to highlight that
application was for c2 use that was for
a care home
not for older people's living so
in planning terms there's a difference a
care home is c2 an older person's home
just because it's age restricted is c3
we have an over provision of
c2 from what the ldp required which is
different
to older people housing furthermore this
application doesn't have any extra care
and has already been discussed i can't
believe it
said it you know that's why since cancer
council haven't been consulted and
haven't raised because
it's considered that um
there hasn't been any but i'm just
thinking back sorry my brain was going
off that actually they only wanted
around 60 in the burnham area and 60 at
modern hege roughly at the
time of the last discussion so for
cleric that was obviously a long time
things may have changed but
i'm assuming that's part of the reason
why there isn't any as part of this
scheme
um just obviously want to highlight the
reference in relation to
strategic sites and it not being a
garden suburb and policy essay etc
we aren't able to um demonstrate a
five-year land supply and
therefore policy sa and us
our segment boundary is our requirement
of trying to deliver our housing within
them and through garden suburbs to a
certain center has fallen away
it's there's a tilted balance now they
are still in material consideration
but they are only that now they're not
we are now working in
the tilted balance so just because
they're outside the certain boundary
isn't
never should be a reason for use
automatically but it can't just be the
reason for
how we word out any objection if there
is an objection
um in relation to head to terms
that is what has been agreed at the
moment and put forward and that would be
what would be part of the legal
agreement
so i can't say much more than that uh
councillor stamp um
also in relation to some of the comments
about what may or may not have been
offered
at the medical center if i recall
correctly some of those conversations
were
brought up at the debate previously and
my advice to members then was to not
give
them any weight we were just talking
about the vision of a medical center
anything or singing or dancing any bells
and whistles was not
on was not part of our informal
agreement it was not part of the
material considerations that officers
came
to when they wanted to plant up
recommended granite plantation at that
time
and therefore shouldn't be consideration
for this particularly as
that medical center has got planning
permission and isn't part of this
application
um and the only
other i think the question mr lee was
the medical center was it to be built
before phase two was passed three
chairman yeah that is quick there is
need to be a level of
services and dwellings fired up and
hopefully with massive 100
confirm this but my understanding are
that the
facilities predominantly on phase one
will need to be required
um to be able to mitigate the harm
but i'm getting a slow knob from his
mouth faster enough yeah miss monkey's
confirmed that is correct so
all those facilities will be required
before phase two
can be occupied and the only other i
think
other point raised was about the minor
adverse impacts on the landscape
you know remember you've all heard me
say a hundred times that you know every
development has some level of impact
and we just need to consider whether or
not the harm is so severe it wants to
reason refusal
um the slight difference is now without
a five-year land supply and when an
application is for housing
whether it's one whether it's a thousand
is that we have to balance whether or
not
the harm significantly outweighs the
benefits and um i think my colleague
would also like to just
make a point if i've covered everything
yesterday
i just wanted to try and give some
context in relation to the housing need
and the locality just to give you a
picture
um and this was a report that was
running alleged to one and two bedroom
bungalows
uh sheltered and linked sheltered and
linked to sheltered
that were advertised between the 1st of
january 2019 for present
so in berlin there were three
one-bedroom properties that were
advertised on our waiting list to give
you a context about the lead
in the first property there were 18
applicants second one there was 22
and the third one there was 17 and there
was one two red bunga that was
advertised and it was not restricted to
northern residents
uh and this advertisement has 48 bids
so there is a need there so one you know
in terms of provision we could
end up with we will almost certainly
fill it and obviously in relation to
community sums
um that goes to build a massive
affordable housing across the district
and also open up to a much wider cohort
than just all those people
okay now um
if you have a point of order please uh
go ahead with it counselor boys
picked
you did yes yeah
yes i i recall that and that that is
noted hm can i say i
did know that cancer person i did
respect that but i'm just advising in
case any other members
were to uh give it different weight to
you and stated just for clarity
okay so i i just want to
well i'll allow the leader to come back
what i'm going to do in a moment is i'm
going to take a vote
on the first officer's recommendation
if that fails then i'll come back to you
councillors
thank you members for allowing me to
come back can i just ask mr lee
um i know we keep coming back to the
magic five-year land supply but
can you put it in perspective that ham i
know you can't give them the exact
number of how many capsules have fallen
below that
i know before covid we were 4.9 and this
council should applaud itself
for actually having a good build-out
rate the number has dropped
significantly because of the economic
circumstances of covid now i know that
there's no political
will from central government to help
councils like us
but we i still feel that we need i
understand what you're saying
but if a development is not suitable and
members deem that it's not suitable
in a location we still need to be
listened to
so i don't know if you can clarify that
but you know that we have built out we
only have to look at burnham's build-out
rate
to know how good this council have been
and i'd like you to be able to
substantiate and back me up on that
please mr lee
chairman um don't have any definitive
figures i have spoken to a number of
essex colleagues and they have agreed
that their five-year land supplies
have produced um one neighbouring
authoritative that's been very
successful
whether this is solely down
um covered i wouldn't be able to comment
you know where
councils are through their local plan
periods can affect that lots of things
um
i totally hear what councillor stanford
said and if i'm honest
i personally may echo some of that but
what on the flip side what i would say
is
however i feel about that the government
is requiring us to do turtle the law
requires us to determine a plan
application current development plan
and as material considerations indicate
otherwise and until there is
any guidance changing that the
government are not
giving any leniency for covid and
therefore we have to determine the
application
around the planning matters not around
how we feel the planning matters should
be
thank you chairman right thank you so
the um
the recommendation uh the first
recommendation was
by councillor morris to refuse this
um now do you want to refine your
grounds councillor morris because
because this is outline
and we can't really go on balkan scale
um i like some of the stuff that when
he's just
uh set i still do think that the scales
are prone
but there's probably better planning
reasons
and just on a side note i'd just like to
bring to everyone's attention because uh
the abandoned carrot that is the 106
agreements has been mentioned quite
extensively
um and if everyone would like to have a
look at the multi-discipline
infrastructure funding statement on
1060s between 1991 and 2020
the total june was 28 million
261 and 78 pence
what was received was five million nine
hundred and fifty eight uh
958 thousand
and fourteen frequent and in the
outstanding
is somewhere around 21 million
600 thousand so um
the 106 agreements are the character are
dangled
but very rarely well that may be
something for
for another committee unless you want to
address that mr lee charlotte
i think i need to comment on that in
case that fell into any material
considerations for any
members during the year it's not a
planning
consideration it would be a plan to set
forth you know fight developments are
phased
payments are phased um they're
off the cuff i can't think of any
application that has not met its
requirements so far through our ldp
allocation
um but for example classified by the
south northern relief road
at the moment we've only had around 150
000 pounds because
that's where we are through the build
out of the phasing development so
that's the issue that you know that we i
wouldn't we can't
we can't say that section of six months
won't come forward one is a legal
requirement but it is a phased delivery
it's not given at the beginning as soon
as you get planning permission thank you
chaim
okay thank you so counselor stamp are
you able to help
um councillor morris with a with a
reason yeah and i don't know if members
can
i'm not brilliant at policy numbers i
thought it was policy s8
and i think it's the countryside will be
protected for landscape natural
resources ecological value
ecology value sorry and the intrinsic
character and beauty
i i actually feel it's this development
would breach
the uh intrinsic beauty of the site
i think it is um there's another one is
it
d1 members are you're gonna have to help
me yeah d1 i think it breaches i'm just
trying to find it on that because i know
mr lee is not allowed to
support us very much a lot more support
when it comes to refusal reason for
approval and
i don't necessarily require members to
quote the exact policies
but all i would want to highlight is
that policy sa is out of date
because we have no five-year land supply
so trying to hang the whole argument on
that policy
but mr lee then all our policies are out
to date
food chain all our policies in relation
to housing location are out of date that
is correct that's what the mppf states
we then need to just consider the good
the planning principles of good
development
rather than um sticking to our strictly
12 plus so for example you've seen
won't say now that a dwelling in a
certain area is unsustainable
so it's not close to facilities the
background evidence that has formed our
policies
in the ldp still exists the need for
good design the need for sustainable
transport the need for ecology historic
environments etc that all still exist
but certain policies are out of date
and it'd be very dangerous to use them
as the driver for our reviews we're
remembering now we have to demonstrate
if we are to refuse it
that the harm significantly outweighs
the benefit so that's
the tilted balance and that's the
difference we can't be looking strictly
on policies we need to be demonstrating
that the harm significantly outweighs
the benefits and i'm not here to say
obviously as officers we don't think
that is and i'm not saying that you
can't come to different conclusion
members
but you need to put forward your
position
with that in mind rather than strictly
on our policies because
i think that'd be a very dangerous
position at appeal thank you okay thank
you can i just go to councillor chana
she's indicated that she wishes to speak
um thank you chairman i think mr lee
said it actually
that officers consider that the home of
this
development the positives outweigh it
i'm afraid i have contrary view i do
believe that the harm of this
development
um is not outweighed by the positives
and it does largely hinge on the
landscape to a degree
and i can refer to the office of report
5.4.11
5.4.1 and 5.413
and it does mention about moderate to
substantial visual effects from
various areas and it says quite clearly
in the report that not all of these
could be
mitigated and it's going to have
significant effect on the views from the
back gardens of properties fronting
malden road and green lane
which would be substantial now that to
me is a significant loss of residential
immunity
residential visual immunity and
therefore i have to disagree this is an
important landscape
i think our landscape assessment
actually has mentioned this type of
landscape it would have
and therefore for me my weight i'm
allowed to do this i've had my planning
training
i can place a different weight to
officers and i'm afraid my weight
is that this development that the harm
it
has does not outweigh um the positives
the harm is greater
i would also add um the leader has
mentioned it about um
links to burnham on crouch the very fact
there has to be a minibus and other
things
we can't escape the fact there's going
to be a lot of car usage
both from the residents on the site and
visitors to it
effectively we are adding because i
didn't vote for the first phase
and i know i've got to look at things
separately in fact what we are doing
here in my book as i've always felt is
an a
isolated enclave with limited
opportunities for integration
with the wider community thank you
chairman that's all i've got to say
thank you thank you
um is that council
but it's all three kilometers away from
the town centre is something that
bothers me
right so um council bell yes
sorry i can't thank you mr chairman yeah
i mean i'd just like to add
and we know this is a tilted balance but
i think we should take heart from
other decisions i gather that a similar
scheme in rochford has recently been
refused
on grounds of significant harm to the
countryside in the landscape
and also we need to bear in mind um
the gladman uttlesford i believe versus
um gladman
where the tilted balance was not
considered to be
in favor of um sustainable land support
by the land supply against um the local
development policy local development
policy was still
considered to have more weight so there
is
some precedent in this area okay thanks
i
i feel i need to ask mr lee to respond
to that um
yeah can i obviously totally
back up and agree with what counselor
channel said i don't just you know i've
always said members you can come to your
own decisions you know and you can give
balance it's just
trying to provide clarity on how we
exactly work things and how
taking into account the legal position
so if members consider that
the impact of this development on those
residents that our reported
analogies would be significant is
warranted refusal
that's within members gift i don't have
an issue with that one at all right
oh that's not sound i agree with any of
them but as a in the planning
uh it's got planned there is okay so i
really
just i'm sorry but yeah i'll say moving
on to in relation to
car usage sash distance what i wouldn't
thus advise is obviously as a council
we accepted this principle at the last
application
and i would just advise members it may
be very dangerous to
go against that now without the reasoned
argument when
previously we have accepted it as
acceptable remembering we are the
council
you know members change office has
changed but the council made the
decision
and the point on the other schemes
firstly
i'd like to highlight two things about
watchful firstly it does have a
five-year land supply
and more important it's in the green
belt which actually is a
one of the exemptions for uh where the
tilted balance doesn't kick in so for
that
even if it didn't have a five-year
landslide and still be in the green belt
so please give that
zero weight um in relation to the
gladman development i
emailed all members on the 4th of may
may 4th um in relation to
that my social i think it was council
belt that raised it um the tilted
balance is still in play that
decision doesn't stay that the tilted
balance doesn't exist
it stands on the shoulders of other case
law that relating to that
matter and it on most one is the
staffordshire which acknowledges that
the starting point will always be the
development plan as material
considerations indicate otherwise
gladman roughly was having a two-part
argument that one that was that
basically your policies all are gone and
they don't matter at all
which is not what officers are saying in
this report not what kath
matthew has said in the debate and not
what i've said it's about balancing them
while they are out of date they're still
a material situation they're just less
weight
and it's the balancing process and
gladly were trying to argue that that
was incorrect
and then the second part was even if you
do have to think about it it's a
two-part test
and as you can see from the officer's
report where ms matthews has very
excellently
dealt with the tilted balance you can
see how we have merged our
policies with the tilted balance to
keep it as one test which is what you
know the judge decided so
that decision never says that utility
balance isn't in play or doesn't exist
it just says that it has to be done
appropriately which i've
envisaged our officers do and i'm just
trying to make sure
in my advice that members do that so
thank you chairman all right thank you
i i i want to go to i want to sort out
actually whose proposal this is going to
be first
um so
councilman morris you've made that
you've made that proposal
yes are we not required to vote on the
officer's recommendation first
it hasn't no it wasn't moved and it
wasn't seconded
so we are going straight to councillor
morris's
if it's going to be your proposal
councillor morris which was seconded by
council of bassinger i believe
yes our members happy to take a vote on
that
right on the on the reasons okay
so i know that uh councillor chana spoke
of the
the reasons it was location and poor
transport links was it
[Music]
my view is the benefits do not outweigh
the harm
to me the harm is more significant and
therefore the positives of the
development the benefits from it are
not greater than the harm that this
development would result in chairman
that's my view and i did mention about
um
transport i think the leader did as well
and
about the distance from burnham on town
you know burnham town itself the leaders
highlighted that
so there are areas and i think it's the
planning reason
the integration with the existing
community i think this um
will not be something that does occur
although then the argument will be from
officers phase one
and also if we're talking about economic
benefits um i couldn't see anything
within the report that actually
substantiated what the economic benefits
are it's all good and well to say it
will mean jobs and everything
but i could see no evidence to weigh up
exactly what that economic benefit was
chairman
thank you thank you and are you
are you okay with atmosphere
firstly that point about benefits hasn't
been
raised previously so it shouldn't be
moved because it hasn't been part of the
debate but i would also just say for
clarity
um that is within the office report it's
relatively standard
economic benefits that you'll see in
every appeal decision so
when a construction development happens
there will be certain level of economic
development
so i would be very conscious to try and
say that there aren't any economic
benefits it's i'm not saying they're
extensive but there will be some
employment opportunities there will be
some
development you know they are covering
the office of a pool and they are fairly
standard so
um it's all part of the tilted balance
what give them the weight you want but
i would just be conscious that it's
fairly standard okay i see a number of
hands going now
so those people who haven't spoken
cancer durham i don't think you've
spoken on this
we're making a bit of a meal of this um
i i think that councillor channel hit
the nail on the head
i would have said and mr lee has agreed
that the reasons for refusal can quite
simply be
that the benefits do not outweigh the
harm of this development
that is that that is that that's the
fundamental issue
we can go into a myriad of other issues
but fundamentally
the harm to the countryside is not
outweighed by the benefits of this
development and that's what i would put
to the vote chairman with respect
so miss bird do you have do you have
sufficient there
you do right members then we
in that case we'll we'll go to uh to the
vote on this so this is to refuse the
application
i'm not going to hear any more now i'm
going to go straight to i'm going to go
straight to the vote thank you i think
this has been well debated
a recorded vote yes you can do that so
members those in favor of refusing this
application
on the grounds that we've that council
channel has spoken about um
miss bird will now take the vote can we
have that precisely
um what are the grounds okay miss bird
are you over to
to call those back big benefits
[Music]
do you like me for clarity i'll provide
some maybe context but
let's oh obviously this won't be the
verbatim
because obviously you know we'll sit
aside and draft that so as always with
all reasons refusal but
um my from hearing what counts done what
counselor channel previously said would
be that
the benefits of the development do not
outweigh the harm
particularly in relation to the
and i can't remember the paragraph the
hot the points related in relation to
impact on the character area and the
those neighbors that were specifically
mentioned
that would be summing up the two points
right i'm going to go to council and
none because he hasn't spoken yet
council none
that this is dealt with properly is
this is councillor morris's proposal yes
is councillor morris prepared to amend
his proposal or to
clarify his proposal by accepting that
though that reason for objection yeah of
course
and councillor passenger you're you're
happy to second that
right so procedurally i think we are
right
uh in that case we'll now go to the vote
please
[Music]
i will abstain
[Music]
four four
[Music]
thank you and therefore that application
is refused
thank you so i think
this is where we say goodbye to
councillor bill
thank you very much
and
thank you members so we'll move on now
to agenda
item seven this is uh twenty
zero one one six six f u
l this is land south charwood
and east of orchard house stoney hills
burnham on crouch this is found on pages
77 to 120 please note there is a members
update that is found on pages 11 and 12
which relate to objection comments
i think this is being presented by miss
staplehurst
so i'll give her a moment uh to
get settled up on the screen
and uh
okay mr davis right okay if you could
please present the report thank you
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought for the construction of an
access road and one dwelling
please note the members update with an
additional public comment just for some
context
this shows where the application site is
located in relation to the wider area
it's located within stony hills which is
an area of residential development
to the northeast of the main settlement
of burnham
these photographs give context of the
site and the stony hills area
you can see that it was a relatively
rural area in 2006
however due to various applications
being approved and allowed on appeal
the area has a more suburban character
currently
you can see the extent of development
that has taken place in the past 15
years
this is the location plan where you can
see the site
outlined in red three dwellings have
been approved surrounding the site in
the blue area
and six dwellings approved to the south
the neighbour to the west orchard house
is indicated on the plan
and there is a new dwelling being built
to these to the south of orchard house
these site plans show the other
dwellings approved within the wider area
and a closer view of the relationship
between the site and the neighbouring
dwellings
the proposed floor plans
and the proposed elevation plans
this application is a resubmission of a
previously refused
outline application that application was
refused due to concerns
from overlooking from the juliet balcony
at
orchard house which is shown in green
and the overlooking that there would be
from the juliet balcony onto the
application site
under this application the dwelling has
been repositioned
so that there is no usable amenity space
between the dwelling and orchard house
and therefore there are no longer
concerns in relation to a loss of
privacy to the application sites
the new dwelling constructed to the
southwest of the site
is considered to be located at a
sufficient distance so it would not
overlook the amenity area of the site
it's noted that concerns have been
raised by objections
with regard to the impacts of the
proposal on orchard house the neighbour
to the west
regarding overshadowing and the impact
on their view
it's noted that this neighbour has a
seating area between the dwelling and
the site
the proposed dwelling would be visible
from this neighbouring site
however the loss of a view is not a
material planning consideration
whilst there could be a minor impact on
the sunlight to some areas of the
neighbouring garden
when the sun is particularly low in the
sky due to the separation distance of
nine point
nine point two meters between the two
dwellings
and the fact that the proposed dwelling
would be single story
it's not considered that there would be
such a material or detrimental
impact in planning terms that would
justify the refusal of the application
it's noted that permitted development
rights will be removed in relation to
outbuildings
extensions and dormers so no further
development would
occur at the site that could impact on
the neighbor in terms of privacy or
light
these photos show orchard house and the
newly constructed
dwelling from the street scene
the view of the proposed access and the
view south
towards the rear of orchard house
these photos are taken from within the
application site
and you can see the rear elevation of
orchard house
with the juliet balcony and the other
neighbor that's under construction
overall when taking into account the
planning history for the area
and all material considerations it's
considered that the development
can be found acceptable and would not
have a materially harmful impact on
neighbouring sites
it's therefore recommended for approval
thank you chairman
thank you mr first um
members i'm going to open the debate and
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments that you have on the report
uh i can't see councillor swain
yes thank you um
[Music]
about this the excess moment
and why does that come up at this stage
when it
seems to apply to service
all the other new developments along
there
and is this turning ahead adequate for
refuge
is it a private road mr uh through you
chairman
uh yes and that access road has been
approved as part
and as part of the applications for uh
the six dwellings to the south
and the three dwellings around the site
um it's just been included in this
application because it's
the access to get to the site but it has
already been approved
thank you chairman thank you councillor
boyce i see you clearly
the officer's
[Music]
well the recommendation members is to
grant planning permission
subject to the 21 conditions that's
proposed
that that is proposed by council of boys
and seconded by
uh councillor durham um councillor
morris has asked for a recorded vote is
that seconded
councillor lagan's second day that
recorded vote
um
anybody else
okay um so any other members wish to
speak on this
councillor
you might sorry i'm sorry to stop you
you may have to wait for the microphone
council lag and sorry
i don't think people can hear you was
there another hand at the back there was
that
councillor durham answer the stamp okay
thank you
um thank you very much it's um
i just said i've read the report when my
device was working
and miss staplehurst's presentation
which i'm appreciative of but i have a
few problems with this
um it strikes me there's a few comments
that were made in there
and and they are some are somewhat
subjective
where the the view of the juliet balcony
where it's previously refused has been
moved it's still going to have
a degree of overlooking which does
concern me it also concerns me about
loss of light
not loss of view we know mr lee's taught
us that
with great detail that the loss of light
although it is is minor
minor loss of light to people who have
positioned themselves in a locality
um to to have a high quality of life
and a sustainable development going
forward with a quite a large
height it's a big old two-bedroom
bungalow um sorry
single-story bungalow so i think on the
on the the grounds of
of the the bulk and the height and the
scale
um i think it would cause demonstrable
harmful for the residents
and i'm not in favor of this this
application based on those reasons
thank you thank you councillor stamp
next and then council channel
it's cancer channel it's not me oh i'm
sorry i thought you had yours
cancer channel
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm happy to let the leader go
next no i'll go last
council channel thank you right okay
looks like it's me
um thank you uh the officer in in the
presentation
um said there was i think i'm correct
and i just like it confirmed only 9.2
meters between the two dwellings
the existing orchard house and the the
new proposal
um the bungalow is going to be about
actually 19
uh whatever can you give it confirm the
height because there's various things
in the report i think you said five
point something meters
about 19 foot at 5.6
right okay so that's in equivalent yeah
quite substantial height
and i think um i made a point about that
um somewhere else
um i do have concerns um about that
um indeed because to me 9.2 metres
between
two dwellings and actually i've seen the
photos there i've seen i'm aware of
other things
and in fact the sunlight is going to be
affected um certainly uh
by that and i do believe there is a
demonstrable harm here
i'm afraid i disagree with the weight
applied again as i said in my earlier
application that's just been up i have a
differing view
on this one as well the way to apply you
did indicate there's no
um about a view that no one has the
right to view and i think council
lagging refer to that
however loss of outlook is a planning
material consideration
and i do consider loss of outlook
applies quite significantly
to should this bungalow be built in the
position that it is
it will have an effect on orchard house
which i
consider myself personally my weight i'm
applying
will be a demonstrable home to orchard
house
the residents there um as well so
i think lots of outlook comes into the
equation and i do believe
demonstrable harm does apply
regarding this development proposal
thank you thank you councillor morris
thank you bona thank you mr chairman
i would just like to bring members
attention to 5.4.5
the very last sentence
overall whilst there may be some impact
in an orchard house is not considered to
be
such a degree as to the material or to
justify the refusal of the application
obviously that possibly wouldn't be the
uh
um the agreement of
the occupiers of orchard house
um i'll go along with what councillor
chana has said and
if councillor boyce's proposal fails
i would invite councillor chana to
second my proposal to refuse
thank you thank you very much
um any other members wish to speak
yes council stephens thank you chair
um in amongst all of the writing that
i've read on this today but i can't find
it at the moment i read
a comment from a resident saying that
the planning application notice
hadn't been displayed can i just hear
from the staff please that that's not
correct
mr first for you chairman um the site
notice has been displayed
um it may have been at the time that
they submitted the comment and it might
not have been or they didn't view it but
it has definitely been displayed
thank you chairman right
thank you members oh yes you want to
come back on that thank you i just
wanted to make sure that it had been
displayed correctly
um and i'm also reading in the report
that the plot has been cleared
so no so further development would
deliver no more harm
doesn't that rather open the floodgates
to developers everywhere clearing plots
and then we have to just go along with
it because the wood or the scrubland or
whatever
has now gone i'd like to understand that
better please
okay mr lee thank you the
state person can bring up the location
plan is probably the easiest way for me
to explain this
as you can see on the plan planning
permission has been granted
for three bungalows on a larger parcel
of land but this piece of land falls
within that
um development and as you can see on the
actual i'm assuming you can see because
actually i can't see the screen but i'm
going to make an assumption that
you can see the six bungalows and the to
the south and then the three that
surround it
so what that is is basically there is a
plot that has been remained
um within the development space that can
accommodate a dwelling in officers
opinions
it's not saying just because someone
clears scrub we will automatically grant
planning permission there's a difference
it's very much a site-specific statement
in relation to the planning history of
the development i hope it's a question
thank you chairman
thank you council councillor stamp next
thing councillors or do you want to go
to councillor swain yes i just wanted to
ask
the officer is the height of this um
building uh going to be um
significantly different from the height
of all the the other bungalows that have
been
already permitted mr rose
through you chairman um i don't have the
dimensions of the other bungalows but it
is a very similar
proportion design it is sort of based on
the other bungalows
thank you chairman
councillor shawnee
um uh chairman on 5.4.5
i think it's on line eight it says the
proposed dwelling
would be located 9.2 metres from the
closest wall of orchard house
now am i correct in remembering i'm sure
the planning offices will put me
uh right if i'm not that there should be
25 meters from building to building
and this isn't mentioned here do forgive
me if i'm wrong but thank you
for your chairman i think there's a
reference to the essex iron guide and if
i'm correct
and i'm shooting from the hips at least
that's relation to first floor windows
rather than i'm getting a nod from the
officer yeah
so it's relation to first floor windows
to stop overlooking it's very different
on single storey properties because
obviously
a normal standard fence provides a
certain level of uh
protection and mitigating harm that you
obviously don't get at first law so
yes essex design guy talked about first
of all not about ground flow since it's
a bungalow so
it wouldn't be relevant in this instance
thank you chairman
thank you very much right uh councillor
stamp
okay thank you thank you chairman and i
actually agree with them councillor
chana
i do have an issue um with this
bungalow being so close yes it may be
is the right distance away um i think
the officer said and i did take a couple
of notes
overlooking it was refused before
because of overlooking the juliet
balcony i don't believe that's changed
does it it's still going to be
overlooked
because of even though it's a bungalow
and it's lower and there's no windows
across the back the whole of that back
bungalow view wall is against a
six foot fence i would imagine i
wouldn't think it'd be any greater than
that any higher than that
which i actually have an issue with no
windows in the back of a whole side of a
house
yes and it could be designed mr lee will
most probably say it's not relevant
cancer stamp
it is relevant the design and people
getting sunlight
as far as i'm concerned is very very uh
important
i actually feel i can't remember if
cancer chenna
used the word contrived but i've heard
it before i think it is contrived i
think this development
this bungalow is contrived and i
certainly don't support it
right thank you in that case then uh i'm
going to go to the vote i think as
i think a vote a recorded vote was
requested and seconded
yeah um so this this
yes please i don't know i think that
council stamps looking at me as though
she wanted me to reply that's why i'm
sorry
sorry if you don't want me i'm happy
in relation to the previous plan
application um that was outlined in
nature
and the applicant indicated that the
bungalow would be at the front of the
site
and that the private means space would
be at the rear and the julep balcony to
the
west would have overlooked this as part
of this application it's a full plan
commission they've actually
sighted the bungalow further to the west
so that while there is a space in the
rear of the property
which um that due to the
limited nature of it and the fact that
the doors would open onto the immunity
space to the side it's considered to not
really be a particularly usable space so
therefore
this is mitigated overlooking because
it's not considered to be
private means space of a usable area
similar to like you'd have on the side
of a traditional dwelling where you know
you'd be able to see down the side of it
and we don't class that to be usable
private immunity space so that
rear has fallen into that so in relation
to usable private immunity space that's
not overlooked
that we consider as officers that it's
now policy compliant
and in relation to the design point um
and impacts on the quality of future
occupiers i just want obviously say
terraced houses or
70 tax houses this property has three
active elevations with windows doors etc
and contains one elevation that doesn't
it's not unusual
for properties to have one elevation
whether it's
a design you know detached one on a side
elevation for example
or obviously if you attack said be
detached or terrorist in relation to
the fact that you've got other
properties there that you won't have
windows so i think arguing that having
one elevation with no form of opening
has an impact on the quality life for
future rock parties
a very limited argument thank you
chairman
you can come back on that yes thank you
i'm just going to come back on that mr
lee because
you always say you take every applicant
application on its own merit
we're not looking at terrorist houses
here we're actually looking at a
bungalow in a development that is
predominantly bungalows or big large
properties and houses
i don't think there's a terrace property
on stony hills like stand corrected if
there is and i will apologize
i don't even think there's a
semi-detached on stoney hills
and so i do feel it's a little bit out
of context but i take and thank you for
your
contribution and the points made i don't
agree with them but i do take on board
what you've said i apologize if i wasn't
clear what i was talking about was
the position that i have in any
elevation
without a window has any automatically
has any evidence of once you impact on
the future occupies
in planning terms i would advise that
that is not a sound basis for a position
even and they're just using the fact
that terrorist housing
in principle has two elevations where
there are no windows on that
and that is a accepted point of planning
that terrorist housing is acceptable so
just as an impact on the quality of life
of future occupiers
i think that's got limited merit that's
all thank you chairman
thank you right okay i'm going to go to
the vote now this is a proposal
to grant planning permission this was
proposed by council of voice and
seconded by councillor
durham
well i don't know i don't know where
he's gonna be
he's left right are we still able to
proceed mr crouch
thank you very much so that is the
proposal the proposal is to grant
uh and miss bird will now take the
recorded votes
well perhaps perhaps i can now we we're
voting on whether to grant
planning permission for this or not so
we're either
for it or against it chairman can i ask
and i don't know the point of order mr
quelch might be able to help me
who proposed this
well surely he has to be in the room if
he's proposed it to take a vote
[Music]
that stands
[Music]
is
right okay thank you very much so we'll
carry on with the vote so this is a vote
to
either yes councilman yeah
um so this is this is to
grant for or against
carry on misfired
[Music]
[Music]
she's not here
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you in that case planning
permission is not granted
um agenda item eight are any other items
of business
[Music]
[Music]
council morris
um
chairman can i come i think councillor
chana's reasons were absolutely spot on
she was concerned about the lack of
light and you think you're there cancer
channel
do we have the microphone please thank
you
um this keeps happening to me i think
people keep quoting my name wanting me
to say things
i think i quoted about loss of outlook
and also i believed i had my applied my
weight differently to the officers where
i believed
there was demonstrable harm should this
application be allowed um
again like i referred to i think like
the previous application i placed
different waiting than the officers did
so
that's my view um i don't um the two
reasons that council most gave us all
due respect
i would like uh to see some additions to
that which is
along the lines i guess of what i said
and which you're referring to leader
okay so so we have in congress and
contrived
a loss of outlook demonstrable harm um
should it be allowed is that correct
do you do you agree that amendment
and uh was it council lagging second did
it
and do you agree with those amendments
council again you do right
can i confirm the councillor channel
when talking about the
harm she was talking about due to loss
of outlook because the way you've just
put it forward was as though that was
its own third reason for refusal
harm standing alone doesn't mean
anything
so yeah so demonstrable harm due to the
outlook
the outlook yes that's correct
[Music]
are you okay with that miss bird
sorry members i just need to communicate
with miss bird sorry
[Music]
okay so we have um the refusal
on the grounds that it is incongruous
and contrived
there is a loss of outlook which is
the demonstrable harm is the loss of
outlook should it be allowed
the development per se because the
offices weighed up the whole development
was the demonstrable harm over such that
the development could go ahead i'm i'm
applying a different weight so yes the
loss of outlook is demonstrable in my
view but also the development itself the
demand for the
to the officer's report
[Music]
um
i think if members have raised from my
understanding would be
that in congress and can try and form
development
which is also a design issue and that
the development would have a detrimental
impact on the neighbours due to a loss
of outlook
which i think are standard reasons for
refusal it's just the randomness of the
demonstrable harm being floated around
that's causing me concern and
mr quelch for one of a better phrase but
if they're the two issues that seems to
be in the debate around
they are their acceptable planning
reasons for refusal thank you chairman
are you satisfied with that counselor
and and mr and cancer
okay those those will those will be the
grounds for refusal then in that case um
so miss bird if we could take the vote
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
oh
abstain thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again
thank you miss bird in that case that is
uh refused
um gender item mate or any other items
of business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent there are
none
in that case i'll move to the closure of
the meeting members
and officers i thank you for your
contributions this evening
i draw the meeting to a close
at 9 39
members are advised not to enter into
any further discussions in this forum
please leave the meeting promptly and
please bear in mind social distancing
thank you